BUT FIRST THE DEMOCRATS LIES IS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
IT WAS THE 1976 FILM "ALL OF THE
PRESIDENT'S MEN" THAT MADE
IMPEACHMENT SEXY.
THE JOURNALISTS CHASED DOWN A
PRESIDENT'S LIES.
>> BERNSTEIN.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
I JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE.
>> OKAY, WE GO WITH IT.
>> Laura: TODAY THE ROLES ARE
REVERSED.
JOURNALISTS AND DEMOCRATS ARE
SPINNING LIES AND THEY ARE NOT
DOING IT WELL.
WE WILL FOCUS ON ONLY FIVE LIES
THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS TOLD IN
THEIR QUEST TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE.
FIRST WHOPPER AND IT'S CLEVER.
STATE YOUR WARPED OPINION,
REPEAT IT AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
THEN CLAIM IT'S A FACT.
>> THE FACTS ARE UNCONTESTED.
THE PRESIDENT ABUSED HIS POWER
FOR ITS ONLY PERSONAL POLITICAL
BENEFIT AT THE RISK OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> THE FACTS ARE NOT CONTESTED.
>> Laura: THAT IS VERY, VERY
CLEVER.
OF COURSE THE FACTS ARE
CONTESTED.
YOU ARE TRYING TO PASS OFF OUR
OPINIONS AND PRESUMPTIONS AS
FACTS.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT GOES WANT NOT
WHEN YOU WANT TO REMOVE A
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE.
THE NEXT LIE IS THE CLAIM THEY
ARE NOT ENJOYING EVERY STINKING
MINUTE OF THIS IMPEACHMENT PUSH.
>> WE DON'T TAKE ANY GLEE IN
THIS.
IT'S HEART BREAKING.
>> WE ARE XHARJD WITH -- CHARGED
WITH A SOMBER RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Laura: AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE REQUESTED AND MY AGENT
FOR THIS AWARD.
BAD ACTING.
THESE PEOPLE ARE TOTAL BROADS.
THE THIRD LIE HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH 2020.
>> THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS AND EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH DEFENDING OUR REPUBLIC.
>> IT'S NOT POLITICAL.
>> THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS.
>> Laura: NICE TRY NANCY.
SHE SAID THIS.
>> I THINK THE MOMENT FOR
COUNTRY WAS A CREDIBLE RESPECT
FROM A WHISTLEBLOWER.
THE POLLS WENT FROM 59 OPPOSED
TO 34 IN FAVOR TO IT.
>> Laura: AH-HA.
NOW THE 4th LIE.
PURSUING IMPEACHMENT WE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE CHANNELLING THE
FOUNDERS.
>> THE FOUNDERS FEARED THE
RETURN OF A MONARCHY IN AMERICA.
>> WE SIT HERE WITH A DUTY TO
THE FOUNDERS.
>> THE FOUNDERS FEARED THEIR
PRESIDENT COULD SUBVERT OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> THE FOUNDERS WORRIED ABOUT
THIS TYPE OF ABUSE OF POWER.
>> Laura: MAYBE THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE FOUNDERS OF THE ACLU.
MAYBE THOSE FOUNDERS.
I CAN ANY TO BRAINYQUOTE.COM AND
TYPE IN MADISON AND JEFFERSON
AND IMPEACHMENT AND COME UP WITH
RANDOM QUOTES TO SUPPORT WHAT I
THINK.
MOST LIKELY THE FRAMERS WOULD BE
HORRIFIED AT THE STATE OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY TO SAY NOTHING OF
THIS RIDICULOUS SPRINT TO A
PRESIDENTIAL TAKE DOWN.
FINALLY THE FIFTH AND MOST
GLARING LIE, DEMOCRATS ARE
AGONIZING HOW THEY WILL VOTE ON
IMPEACHMENT.
>> I WANT TO RESERVE JUDGMENT.
>> I WILL RESERVE ANY KIND OF A
PUBLIC JUDGMENT.
>> I HAVE TO RESERVE JUDGMENT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
I AM SURE NADLER, SCHIFF AND
PELOSI ARE POURING OVER THE
TRANSCRIPTS TONIGHT AND PARSING
EVERY WORD OF THE TRUMP ZELENSKY
TRANSCRIPT.
DID HE MEAN DO ME A FAVOR?
THE TRUTH IS NANCY PELOSI LOST
CONTROL OF HER CAUCUS IN LATE
SUMMER WHEN THE THINKING OF
SCHIFF AND THE SQUAD PREVAILED.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS TO GO.
THEY COULD NOT RISK THE
POSSIBILITY OF HIM BEING
REELECTED IN 2020.
PEOPLE MIGHT REELECT HIM FOR
ANOTHER 4 YEARS.
THEY HAD TO MOVE TO IMPEACH HIM
WITH WHATEVER THEY HAD.
A GRAB BAG OF RIDICULOUS IDEAS,
CHARGERS AND SUPPOSITIONS.
EVEN IF IT WAS BASED ON HEARSAY,
CONJECTURE AND LIES.
IF PELOSI, NADLER AND SCHIFF
TOOK THEIR DUTIES OF THE
CONSTITUTION SERIOUSLY THEY